[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
we've got very loyal viewers they watch
carefully they search to see if they can
find one mistake so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
nobody's ever caught us making mistake
we're that precise well ten well tonight
tonight a fan named Teddy Chow says he
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened during one of her regular
comedy bits this is the video he sent in
High Conan I found an error in your
segment bus needs running out of lists
the third listed that bit was entitled
twelve Egyptian mummies that are still
DTF an item one was a photo of a mummy
with the caption hold on baby
I'm Tutankhamun 12 Egyptian mummies that
are still DTF the mummy in the photo was
in a museum exhibit display case but
Tutankhamun's mummy has always had its
original tomb as his permanent residence
in fact he's only ever exited the tomb
twice once in 1925 for physical and once
again in 2005 to get a CT scan but both
times he never travelled further than a
few meters away from the tomb entrance
so Conan I think I got you he cuts a bit
of a homebody and he wouldn't be caught
dead in a museum exhibit display case I
have to say that guy did an amazing job
I mean did he not do it beautiful yeah
the setting the setting the location
right his presentation he ended with a
joke wouldn't be a beautiful job there's
just one problem and that is this Teddy
you are dead wrong you're just wrong
King Tut's mummy does leave its tomb it
leaves its tomb all the time and I can
prove it you see as impressive as your
video looks
it was clearly doctored that's a
doctored video fortunately through a lot
of research we were able to get our
hands on the original version before you
were able to alter it and send it in and
the original version proves I'm right
you're wrong roll the original hi Conan
I found an area in your segment bus
speeds running out of bliss the third
list of that bit was entitled 12
Egyptian mummies that are still DTF an
item one with photo of the mummy with
the catching hold on baby
I'm Tutankhamun
the mummy in the photo was in the museum
but teaching comics Plumbing has always
had its original tune as a permanent
resident in fact he only ever
[Music]
a bit of a homebody
and you wouldn't be caught dead
[Applause]
[Music]
not only because Tutankhamun leaves he
goes around giving people computer up in
the bird hanging from a helicopter so
the challenge still stands if you think
do you think you've spotted an error on
our show reporter a team koco.com / how
I find an error we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
little break
you